وهران لابيرمان ، دعنا نعيدك إلى
شخص ما سألك عن هذا
الشريط الصوتي الذي ظهر
أنه تبادل بين
الجنود الأوكرانيين الذين يدافعون عن جزيرة البحر الأسود وهم
يلعنوا على سفينة حربية روسية قبل
أن يُقتلوا في معركة أريدك أن
تستمع إلى هذا
الأجنبي.
[موسيقى] [موسيقى]
أجنبية
[ضحك]
نجاح باهر الأوكرانيون يتحدون المشرق أو
أنهم لا يتراجعون عن
شيئين كانا مؤكدًا الدخول في
هذا وهذا ما قيمناه
أولاً أن روسيا لديها جيش متفوق بشكل كبير
وقوات مسلحة
مبنية  حول أوكرانيا وأن
جيش أوكرانيا قد لا يكون قادرًا على
الصمود كل هذا الوقت الطويل سواء كانت تلك
الأيام أو الأسابيع غير واضحة ولم
يكن البنتاغون في طريقه إلى معرفة كيفية حدوث
ذلك بالنسبة للروس ولكن
الشيء الآخر الذي كان واضحًا هو ذلك  إذا
اختار الروس أن يصبحوا قوة احتلال
بعد هذا الغزو ، فإن الأوكرانيين
سيضعون جحيمًا واحدًا في قتال
وتمرد ضد الاحتلال الروسي
ربما ضد.  حكومة دمية روسية
وتلك الروح
التي ستقاتل تلك الرغبة في الوقوف
ضد روسيا وأن تكون أوكرانيًا ،
هذا ما تسمعه في هذا
الفيديو وهذا ما تسمعه من
مراسلينا الموجودين في أوكرانيا
ويتحدثون إلى الأوكرانيين  على الأرض
هناك
حق
[موسيقى]
هنا في العاصمة الأوكرانية بدأنا
نسمع انفجارات في حوالي الساعة الخامسة صباحًا
هذا الصباح ، لقد سمعت للتو انفجارًا آخر ،
أوه أقول لك ما سمعت للتو دويًا كبيرًا
هنا ورائي هناك
انفجارات كبيرة تحدث
في كييف الآن
[موسيقى]
أنت